- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is Go
Hard, over to you G Easy.
(rooster crowing)
(funky music)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin',
I wake up every mornin'.
- Go hard and then when you
think you're goin' hard,
then go harder, like that's
really it, just hustle.
You know what I mean,
there's nothin' in life that
you can't put enough
work in every single day
and not get better at,
you know what I mean?
Like if you want to be
good at something, you know
what I mean, like you can't
just like not do it every day
and not get better, it's
the same shit with music.
It's the same shit as
learnin' how to play an
instrument or somethin',
if you spend you time
practicing your craft, like
ya know, that's really it.
It's just, 'cause nowadays
with the internet,
everything is so accessible
and everybody in the
world is a rapper, you know what I mean.
Everybody's puttin' music
out so it's like how
do you stand out, quality's
always going to matter.
But also bein' different, you
can't try to be different.
Ya know what I mean, but
you just got to be yourself.
- Every major breakthrough
that you'll have in your life
will come from raising your standards.
Every major breakthrough
that you'll have in your life
will come from raising your standards.
You may tell yourself
that you're working hard.
You may think that you're
working hard right now
in your business, maybe
for you working hard means
ya know, x number of
hours and in the past,
whenever you worked less than
that, you felt like a slacker
but now you feel like you're working hard.
Maybe compared to your
friends or your family
or the people around you,
you're working really hard.
Maybe they tell you you're
working really hard.
So you feel like you're
But you're not getting
the result that you want.
And maybe it's time that you need to
raise your standards a little bit.
I bet if I came in, if you
said that you're working hard
and I came I and audited
your day, there'd be
a ton of wasted time and
I'm not just talking about
now you need to wake up
an hour early or two hours
early and get more work done.
Sleep the same number
of hours, look in the
16, 17 hours that you are
awake, there's a lot of
wasted time in there, whether
it's checkin' your social
media, refreshing your email
all the time, responding
to a crisis that isn't
really a crisis, not spending
your time on the valuable
things that you need to
do to grow your business,
constantly being interrupted
and distracted and it's
not their fault they're
interrupting and
distracting you, it's your
fault for allowing it to happen.
There's a ton of wasted
time in what you're
doing every single day
and as long as you think
that you're working hard,
as long as you think that
you're doing your best, then
you're never going to do better.
If you say this is the
best I can do, you're never
going to do better and you're
going to be stuck where you are.
Now you're happy where you are, great.
But don't complain that you want more.
Don't complain that you
want more and you're
not willing to raise your
standards and put in the work
and get better to get there.
So I look at the change
in my schedule where now
I'm recording all my
videos as a test, all my
videos in one day, once a
month for the entire channel,
making 70 videos in one day
and when we first came up
with this idea, I'm like I
like it, I like the push.
I don't know if I can do it,
I don't know if I'm going to
be able to sustain but I
want the challenge to test
it and see because I already
thought I was doing a lot
'cause everybody around me
would say, listen, you're
making three videos a day, that's crazy.
How do you make three
videos a day where most
people working hard is
making, even a video a day
is considered working really hard.
We're doing three a day
and to record them all once
a month is nuts but I want the test.
I want to see where my limits are.
If you're never pushing for your limits,
then you don't know what you can do.
If I said the best I
can do is once a week,
then that's what I'm
going to stick to doing.
And I'm going to be wasting some time.
So I'm going to try,
this is our first test.
Doing once a month, can we make it happen?
Can I still be good
making 70 videos in a day?
Can my team handle the influx
and get everything ready?
Do I lose momentum and
I'm okay with failing.
I'm okay with it not
working out but I'm not
okay with not knowing and
so you want to be taking
on challenges to push
yourself, to understand where
your limits are and work
on busting through them.
Every major growth that
you have in your life,
every single major move
forward will become
by adjusting your standards.
When you demand more from
yourself, when you start
teaching people how to treat
you, that's when you're
going to get the next
major breakthrough in
your life and in your business.
(whooshing)
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious.
What was the last standard
that you raised for yourself?
In your life or in your
business where you said,
I'm no longer willing to
tolerate this anymore.
My new standard is up
here, this is what I want
to accomplish, what was
that last one for you.
Leave it in the comments and
we'll join in a discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tom Pelton.
Tom, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to
me, man, and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever Your One Word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
(funky music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it.
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- For four years, I street performed
here before I got my record deal.
I was on the streets with
a little bitty keyboard
with glasses on like I was
Stevie Wonder, ya know.
Hustilin', ya know, with
a big Chitlin Bucket.
I paid my rent and my mom's
rent off of street performin'.
But I would only do it
three days out of the week.
Just three weeks but I would
be I can't talk no more.
I can't even talk because
I was like singin' for
like eight hours straight
for people goin' to work
and comin' from work.
(piano music)
And then I would hitchhike to
LA but I lived on the beach.
Cardboard box and big
beach towels I slept on.
- On the beach?
- On the beach.
Every day and then I wake
back up and, and when
I wake up I sing again
and I came, I hitchhiked
back to Chicago and then I got discovered.
But I did all that for like
six years, street performing.
- Well, a lot of artists
don't know that they got to
get on the God damned road
and tour, you know what I'm
sayin', you got to get the
people knowin' about you, man.
Not just your hot single,
man, you got to get out
there and politic, how do you politic?
Through tourin', man,
you know what I'm sayin'.
Merchandise, you got a
shirt with your name on it.
You got a hat with your
name on it, you know,
these people are walkin'
billboards, you know.
- Exactly.
- You got to get out
there and politic, man and
that's how we did it, man.
We just stayed on the road,
if there were like seven
people in the audience when
we went, we didn't say,
okay, we ain't goin' back
to San Diego 'cause they're
only seven people there
or we ain't goin' back to
New York 'cause we only
had 10 people there.
We kept comin' back and
hammerin' 'em over the head.
And the seven turned to
100, the 100 turned to 500,
ya know what I'm sayin',
to sellin' out every time
so we had to change venues,
you know what I'm sayin'.
You got to get out there
and politic, you got to get
out there and tour, you
got to get out there
and sell your merchandise,
man and a lot of people,
ya know, they ain't going to
tell you this but it take a
little money to start your
own label, you feel me?
It'll take a little money to
start it, you know what I mean.
So all you niggas sellin'
that in that hood,
put it into somethin' good.
- A lot of people don't
realize it's like, you
got to work for somethin',
you got to want it, ya know.
I thank the man up above I
was able to change my life
and do what I'm doin'
and got a second chance
with education, I educated
myself even though I
was in the streets, I educated myself.
And I thank the man all the
time, like you know what,
you got to have a good piece
of mind 'cause a lot of people,
they just want you to give 'em somethin'.
Even these orders of the
day, I'm like from all
this to friends or
whatever, everybody lookin'
for a handout.
- Right.
- No body really want to
work no more, you know.
- I feel the same way, a lot of interns
and people like that, when we
came, we was bustin' our ass.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And now people expect things.
- See, people don't know,
like I actually sold
Cds out of the trunk of my car.
I went from city to city, now,
you know, guys are comin',
they want, they look at a
guy like me, man, you know,
put me on, you got a mixed tape.
You want me to give you some money.
I'm not givin' you no
money for no mixed tape.
You know what I'm sayin',
a mixed tape is free.
You got to get your hustle,
you got to build your brand.
And then get the opportunity,
if I had opportunity to
get with a Master P or somebody, you know,
but I guess this generation
don't want to learn,
like I say, everybody gettin'
high, you know what I'm
sayin', the syrup is killin'
the whole, this generation.
- You now, a lot of people
don't recognize opportunity
if there's not a paycheck attached to it.
- Yeah, sometime you don't
have to work for the money.
If you do what you got
to do and you're good
at it, the money going to come,
you got to love what you doin'.